[Music]
Hi everyone, I'm George, co-founder of
Artificial Analysis. A quick background
to who we are before we dive into
things.
Do you see that?
I think my clicker is not working.
Click.
Oh, there we go. Great. So, a quick
background to who we are. We're a
leading independent AI benchmarking
company. We benchmark a broad spectrum
across AI. So, we benchmark models for
their intelligence. We benchmark API
endpoints for their speed, their cost.
We also benchmark uh hardware and all
the AI accelerators out there. Uh and we
also benchmark a range of modalities,
not just language, but also vision,
speech, image generation, video
generation, and we publish essentially
nearly all of it uh for free on our
website artificialanalysis.ai
AI whereby we benchmark over 150
different models uh across a range of
metrics. We also publish reports many of
which are publicly accessible and we
also have uh a subscription for
enterprises looking to uh enter uh or
bring AI to production in their
environments um in an efficient uh and
effective way.
Let's start off with AI progress. Let's
set the scene. So, it's been a crazy two
years. I think that we've all felt it in
this room whereby OpenAI uh kicked off
the race uh with the chat GBT and GBD
3.5 launch. And since then, it's only
gotten more hectic. There's been more
and more uh model releases by more and
more labs pushing the AI frontier.
So the current state now of frontier AI
intelligence. I think this will be this
order of models will be familiar to a
lot in this room. O3 is the leader but
followed closely by 04 mini with
reasoning mode high. Deepseek R1 the
release in the last week or two. Rock 3
mini reasoning high Gemini 2.5 Pro
Claude 4 opus thinking
this benchmark is our artificial
analysis intelligence index it's made up
of a composite it's a composite index of
seven evaluations
which we then wait to develop our
artificial analysis intelligence index
which just provides a generalist
perspective on the intelligence of these
models.
We all have an understanding of what
frontier AI intelligence is. But what I
want to explore with you today is that
there's more than one frontier in AI.
There's trade-offs to accessing this
intelligence. You shouldn't always use
the leading most intelligent model. And
so what we want to do is we want to
explore the different frontiers out
there. And as an AI benchmarking
company, we're going to bring some
numbers to the four to help you reason
about this. First, we'll be looking at
reasoning models. Next, we'll be looking
at the open weights frontier. Third, the
cost frontier. And lastly, the speed
frontier. There's other frontiers out
there that we benchmark, but we'll focus
on these key ones today.
Starting with reasoning models, what
we've done here is we've taken our
intelligence index and looked at that
relative to the output tokens used to
run the intelligence index. So we've
measured all of how many tokens each
model took to run our seven evaluations
and we've plotted it on this chart and
you can see two distinct groups. It's
helpful to think about these separately.
So non-reasoning models which offer less
intelligence but uh require fewer output
tokens
and reasoning models which use more
output tokens but offer greater
intelligence
and the more this is important to look
at because more output tokens comes with
trade-offs both for request latency as
well as cost. We're going to bring some
numbers to draw that out and look at the
real differences here.
Starting with output tokens and the
verbosity of these models, just how
yappy these reasoning models are. We can
see that there's an order of magnitude
difference between reasoning and
non-reasoning models. It's not just that
feeling, oh, this is taking a long time.
It's real. It's an order of magnitude.
So between GPT 4.1 it uh it required 7
million tokens to run our intelligence
index evaluations but then 04 mini high
took 72 million tokens and the yappiest
of them all Gemini 2.5 uh pro took 130
million tokens to run our intelligence
index
and as mentioned this has implications
for cost as well as N10 latency
responsiveness
So looking at latency, we benchmark the
API latency of how long it takes to
receive a response when accessing these
models via their APIs.
Here we can see that GBD 4.1 on median
across our requests took 4.7 seconds to
return a full response.
04 mini high took over 40 seconds,
roughly another 10x or order of
magnitude increase. This has
implications for applications and users
which require responsiveness even
enterprise uh kind of chat bots. You
don't always reach for 03 in chat GPT
and it and Facebook's done a lot of
studies on this where they've looked at
the for consumer apps where they've
looked at uh user drop off by lat uh
application latency which clearly
demonstrate this. Sorry, do you mind if
we jump back a slide?
And it also has uh implications for how
we're building. So I think particularly
with agents whereby 30 uh queries in
succession is not uncommon.
It has it's a multiplier effect on the
latencies uh for your application and
how you can build. If you have faster
responses, maybe you can make that 30 uh
100 queries for instance. And so putting
numbers to that in terms of agents, 30
is normal. And so even less than than 04
mini, maybe you're at 10 seconds for a
reason model. If you're running 30
queries, that's 300 seconds that a user
might be waiting for a response or an
application might be waiting for a
response. That's 5 minutes.
If with the order of magnitudes that
we're dealing with here, if that 10
seconds was 1 second, then those 30
queries takes 30 seconds. 30 seconds
versus 5 minutes impacts what you can
build. Think of a contact center uh
application that might maybe 30 seconds
is okay there, but 5 minutes uh
definitely not. Who likes waiting on the
phone uh that long or imaging
numbers to these trade-offs is really
important. I'd encourage everybody to
measure them.
Next, we're going to move to the open
weights.
Around the time of GPT4, there was a
huge delta in terms of open weights
intelligence
proprietary intelligence.
Llama 65B or LMA 270B wasn't close to
the intelligence of GPT4.
What I'd like to show here is where we
plot our intelligence index by release
date is that that gap it closed
until with with great models like
mixture late time 7 and uh LM45B.
But 01 broke away in late 2024.
But then of course I think we remember
Deepseek released V3 I think December 26
ruined some of my Christmas holiday
plans.
Had to tell my family I I need to go
read this paper. It's really exciting.
And then of course R1 in January. The
gap between open weights intelligence
and proprietary model intelligence
is less than it's ever been,
particularly with the recent R1 release
in the last couple of weeks, which is
only a couple of points different in our
intelligence index to the leading
models.
You can't talk about open weights
intelligence without talking about
China. The leading open weights models
across both reasoning models and
non-reasoning models are from China
based AI labs. Deepse seeks leading in
both. Alibaba with their Quen 3 series
is leading is coming in second in
reasoning.
But you also have other labs such as
Meta uh and Nvidia with their Neotron
fine tunes of Llama coming in close as
well.
Let's look at the cost frontier. This is
really important and I think similar to
re to uh end latency impacts what you
can build. So bringing some numbers
here, we can really see these order of
magnitudes play out.
So 03 cost us $2,000 to run our
intelligence index. Techrunch actually
wrote an article about how much money we
were we were spending on running evals.
We we didn't want to read it.
You can see 4.1 a great model. It's 30
times roughly cheaper in terms of the
cost to run our intelligence index
compared to 01 and 4.1 nano over 500
times cheaper to run our intelligence
index than 03.
You should think about these when
building applications. the kind of cost
structure of your application might
dictate what you can use here
and how you use them. Those 30 uh
sequential uh API calls for your agentic
application could be uh 500 and still be
cheaper than an 03 query.
A key point to note here with this cost
to run intelligence index and why we
don't just look at the per token price
is that and the labs maybe don't want
you to think this way but you're paying
for the cost per token but then you're
also paying for how verbose the models
are. All the reasoning tokens that are
output when these models are in their
thinking mode.
you pay for those as output tokens even
if some of the labs hide them. And so
you need to think about this and measure
it in your application not and benchmark
not just by the cost per million tokens
but also considering how many reasoning
tokens there are and how verbose these
models are. You can see even amongst the
non-reasoning models there's big
differences between how verbose these
models are in responses.
So for instance, ah we'll go to the next
slide.
Do you mind if we go back one please?
So what we've done here is we have now
we're now going to look at the trends in
terms of cost. And so what you can see
here is we've bucketed models by how
intelligent they are. intelligence uh
bands, if you will. And what we can see
here is that accessing GPT4 level of
intelligence has fallen over a 100 times
since mid23.
This is the case across all quality
bands.
You can see that even when a new quality
band a new frontier is reached 01 mini
in late 24
quickly within only a few months the
cost of accessing that level of
intelligence h haveved this is moving
quickly and so what I would say to you
is when building applications
think about what if cost wasn't a
barrier when you're building it's a it's
a very important kind of cost uh
exercise because it might well
that if you build for a cost structure
that doesn't work now, then maybe in 6
months time that will be uh possible and
it will be uh feasible.
Next, we're going to look at the speed
frontier. So this is how quickly you're
receiving tokens, the output speed,
output tokens per second that you're
receiving after sending an A API
request.
This has been increasing and has
increased dramatically since early 23 as
well.
So similarly, we've because there's a
trade-off typically between intelligence
and speed, we've grouped models into
certain buckets. And we can see here
that they've all increased in terms of
how quickly you can access a level of
intelligence.
So 40 I believe was around 40 output
tokens per second. Now you can access
that was in 2023.
Who remembers hitting it wasn't a
reasoning model hitting enter in chatbt
and just waiting for it to output
especially code which you want to just
copy straight into your editor and you
know hit run see if it works now you can
access that level of intelligence at
over 300 tokens per second
that I'll go through it's not the focus
of the talk but important to to
reference model sparity so we're seeing
more
mixture of experts models and
They activate only a proportion of uh
parameters at inference time less
compute per token which means it can go
faster essentially and were around back
then but they're getting more and more
proportion
next
models are getting more uh intelligent
particularly with distillations you know
8B distillations etc.
inference software optimizations like
flash attention and speculative decoding
and lastly hardware improvements. So
H100 was faster than A100. Now we've
recently launched benchmarks of the B200
on our artificial analysis website and
it's getting over a,000 output tokens a
second. Think about that relative to the
40 output tokens per second of GPT uh 4
in 23.
There's also specialized uh accelerators
like Cerebra, Samova, Grock.
I want to share a house view here to
frame things.
Yes, things are getting more efficient.
Yes, the cost of accessing the same
level of intelligence is decreasing and
hardware is getting better. We're
getting more system output throughput
on our on the chips.
But our view is that demand for compute
is going to continue to increase.
We're going to see larger models. I mean
deepseek it's over 600 billion active uh
sorry not active total parameters
and the demand for more intelligence is
insatiable. Reasoning models, as we saw,
the yappy models, they require more
compute at inference time. And lastly,
agents
whereby 20, 30, 100 plus
uh sequential requests to models is not
uncommon. These actors multiplies on the
demand for compute. And so the house
view playing with these numbers is net
net. We're going to continue to see
commute compute demand increase.
Thanks everyone.